Traductor: Judit Rodríguez
Revisor: Venecia Romanillo-Evaristo
Se han puesto a pensar,
¿quiénes serían ustedes
si no tuvieran recuerdos?
En esta sala hay un asesino
y todos nosotros somos cómplices.
Para el 2050, en nuestro país
habrá un incremento del 447%
de casos de Alzheimer.
¿Saben qué significa esto?
Que en 38 años,
tú o yo
seremos una persona que tenga Alzheimer,
o estaremos cuidando de alguien.
Y estas estadísticas
no nos están alarmando
y tendrían que hacerlo.
Te lo pongo más sencillo.
Te explico cómo ocurre,
porque el cuento del Alzheimer
no es como nos lo contaron.
Sólo el 10% de los casos son hereditarios
y el 90% es culpa nuestra.
La población mundial tiene
el 40% de probabilidad
de tener el gen del Alzheimer,
pero dependerá del estilo de vida
de cada uno de nosotros
manifestarlo o no.
Además, ¿saben cuántas personas
tienen diabetes
o presión alta en Bolivia?
Mi mamá tiene, y créanme que para mí
es una preocupación continua.
Déjenme explicarles un poco
cómo funciona el Alzheimer.
Yo crecí con Pac-man.
Pac-man es muy parecido a lo que vivimos
con el Alzheimer.
Pero les cuento para aquellos
que están muy jóvenes
y no lo conocen todavía.
Pac-man en esta historia es el bueno,
pero tiene una misión:
tiene que comer cada una de las pastillas
que están en el laberinto
y lograr ganar el juego.
Existen sus archienemigos:
los fantasmas.
Uno que otro medio aventurero
y otros que están medio escondidos.
Y estos intentarán, a toda costa,
arruinarle la vida a Pac-man.
Pero Pac-man tiene un superpoder
y si es que come la súper pastilla,
tiene la capacidad
para adquirir poderes como
súper velocidad
y hacer vulnerables a sus enemigos.
Así obtiene una ventaja
y logra ganar el juego.
Simple.
¿Qué ocurre entonces en la vida real?
En la vida real solo cambia
una sola cosa.
Déjenme decirles algo:
En la vida real,
Pac-man es el malvado.
Pac-man representa el Alzheimer.
¿Qué es el Alzheimer entonces?
El Alzheimer es una
enfermedad neurodegenerativa,
progresiva e irreversible.
Exactamente como Pac-man.
Cada vez que Pac-man da un paso al frente,
y come cada una de nuestras neuronas,
está eliminando un recuerdo.
Imaginen lo siguiente:
estoy caminando por la plaza
y de repente
me encuentro perdida.
¿Por dónde queda mi casa?
¿Cuál era el número de teléfono
de mi casa?
Eh, ¡disculpe señor!
¿Usted sabe cómo llegar a...?
¿Pero cómo se llama la calle donde vivo?
¿Cómo se llaman las personas
con las que vivo?
Y en realidad, me empiezo a dar cuenta
de que no estoy perdido a nivel físico,
sino que acabo de perder
mi historia personal.
Y además mi identidad.
En ese momento es cuando mis pacientes
empiezan a llegar.
En ese momento es cuando acudo
a un neurólogo o a un psiquiatra,
y empiezan un tratamiento farmacológico.
Lastimosamente, esta es una etapa
muy avanzada.
Suena muy triste la historia.
Y, la verdad, es muy triste verlo.
Pero aún así, cada uno de nosotros
somos unos luchadores
porque en nuestro cerebro albergamos
la reserva cognitiva.
La reserva cognitiva es una barrera
que acumulamos con el paso de los años.
Esos cafecitos en casa, con la familia,
que nos juntamos, nos reunimos y
la pasamos muy bien.
Cuando vemos que la abuelita
está tejiendo una chompa,
unos postres deliciosos.
Esa pasión por la música,
por el cine, por el arte.
Por hacer todo eso,
genera una barrera protectora.
Esos años cansados
de estudio en el colegio,
en la universidad, en la maestría,
en los posgrados...
Créanme, son vitales
para poder crear esta barrera.
Tener la capacidad de hacer
las cosas por ti mismo.
Que nadie te ayude,
sentirte útil a cada momento
es parte de nuestra reserva cognitiva.
¿Y saben por qué
esto es tan impresionante?
Esto es porque cada uno de nosotros
pone muchas de sus emociones
en esta vida.
Y cuando uno entrega todo de sí,
genera emociones positivas y negativas.
A veces, Pac-man tiene una ventaja.
A veces, cuando llegamos
a la edad de los 56 años,
en el trabajo vienen con una gran noticia.
¡Felicidades!
Lo has hecho muy bien,
gracias por tu servicio.
Retírate.
Y pasas a ser una persona
sedentaria, inútil, frágil,
después de haber sido
un gerente multinacional.
Y no me estoy inventando el caso: es real.
Y en ese momento
empiezas a dudar de ti mismo.
Y ese momento de crisis
empieza a afectar a tus emociones
y hace que el Alzheimer
avance con tal fuerza
que probablemente el tratamiento
farmacológico no nos ayude.
¿Saben qué es perder la muerte
de un ser querido?
Imagínense perder a la persona
que los acompañó por toda la vida.
¿Qué? ¿Cuánto estamos casados?
¿20, 30, 50 años?
¿Saben la cantidad de recuerdos
que acumulamos con esas personas?
Son muchísimos.
Y esa tristeza nos arrebata los recuerdos.
Aquí es donde llega el equipo de élite:
los psicólogos y neuropsicólogos.
A veces somos muy tímidos para expresar
quién realmente somos.
Entonces el trabajo que realizamos
es mostrarle a la persona
que todo eso que guardó por tanto tiempo,
todo ese dolor, todas esas alegrías,
las puede traer al presente.
Y al recordar el pasado,
vive cada día de una manera diferente.
Está vacío.
Me encantaría decirles que
la historia con el Alzheimer,
y a pesar de tener
un tratamiento farmacológico
y además, tener a los especialistas
en psicología, en neuropsicología...
¿genera una solución?
No.
En la vida real
el Alzheimer siempre gana.
Y se lleva tus logros,
se lleva a tu familia,
se lleva tu identidad,
se lleva tu capacidad
para seguir con vida.
¿Vamos a dejar que esto nos gane?
Es la pregunta que le hacemos
a cada uno de los familiares y cuidadores
de estas personas con Alzheimer.
Cuando una persona
recibe el diagnóstico de Alzheimer,
aún le queda como 5 a 10 años de vida.
Pero para la familia es algo muy duro.
Tener que saber que
su familia no lo va a recordar
y que además, probablemente
va a morir con esto.
Pero, ¿continuamos?
¿Se animan?
¿Creen que hay una opción todavía?
En la Asociación Alzheimer Bolivia,
a nosotros no nos da la gana
dejárselo fácil.
Vamos a hacer todo lo posible por que,
aunque no podamos cambiar
el final de la historia,
la manera en que lo vivimos
va a ser espectacular.
Entonces, nosotros brindamos un espacio
donde estos adultos mayores
siempre ven una cara sonriente,
siempre tienen una mano
para acompañarlos en esos paseos,
donde la familia puede ver
que vivir con Alzheimer
es solamente una nueva manera de vivir,
como lo es vivir con cualquier enfermedad.
Me gustaría contarles la historia de ella.
Sólo mírenla.
Ella fue mi primer paciente.
Lo es aún.
Ella no me recuerda.
(Solloza)
Grave, ¿no?
(Aplauso)
Aunque yo no tengo
una familia con Alzheimer
y no hay un historial
de Alzheimer en mi familia,
ver día a día cómo
estas familias tienen que luchar
y ver que esta persona jamás
les va a volver a llamar por su nombre,
y van a ser unas personas X en su vida...
Realmente, toca nuestras vidas.
Me encanta que cuando
yo la miro y le digo:
"Señora Neli, ¿cómo está?"
Ella sabe en lo más profundo de su ser
que aunque no conoce mi nombre
y tampoco conoce mi cara
hay algo en ella que le dice
que estar conmigo es un lugar seguro.
Que estar con esas personas que
día a día dan de su tiempo
para poder tener los oídos atentos
y los ojos mirándolos,
hace que vivir con Alzheimer sea posible
y además, sea una vida feliz.
Y cuando llegue el final,
la familia está segura de que entregó
los mejores momentos
y creó nuevos recuerdos,
no solamente con su mamá, con su papá,
sino con un nuevo amigo.
¿Saben?
Bolivia no está preparada
para ese 447%.
Y de ese 447%, el 90%
somos culpables nosotros.
Les voy a dar tres formas
de luchar juntos contra el Alzheimer.
Primero:
Deja de alimentar a Pac-man.
Duerme bien, ten un tiempo contigo.
Deja de tener una vida tan estresante,
dedica tiempo para ti y descansa.
Ya sabes las consecuencias de esto.
Segundo:
Todo lo que estás haciendo en tu vida
va a servir para algo.
El laberinto es una pieza
tan importante en esto,
porque mientras más difícil sea,
mas difícil se lo vamos
a hacer el juego a él.
Hagamos que Pac-man se pierda.
Y que con tantos recuerdos,
no abastezca para destrozarlos.
Y tercero:
A cada momento pónganle una emoción.
Mientras más fuertes son las emociones,
mayor es el recuerdo.
Vivan intensamente
y generarán atajos
que su cerebro encontrará maneras
para luchar contra el Alzheimer.
Unidos, en familia,
conectados con nuestros amigos,
con nuestra comunidad,
lograremos luchar contra el Alzheimer.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)